- tiger belly but up up up Papa my name
is Bob we got kalila we got Gilbert
Gilbert Gilbert Gilbert Gilbert I first
want to start off by saying thank you
for my fans and our fans from Chicago
that came to the show you know I I enjoy
meeting you I enjoy touching you and
enjoy hugging you and I enjoy all of it
I also want to have a little
conversation with Gilbert here oh you
just said to me thank you for being nice
to my family yeah so what do you mean by
that they all came out to see Bobby sure
Laden came out some came Friday I think
some came Sunday what do you think I was
gonna do because you you you said you
were worried that I was gonna say
something to them not really worried no
you said that so what would I say hey
you go over to Uncle yeah
your nephew sucks dick yeah but you know
what can I just say something can I just
see something you I got a class baby I
know and I got intuition mm-hmm and I've
got a morality all right
why would I [ __ ] do that I don't know
I'm not gonna expose them to you're like
it's not my lifestyle don't see your
eating behavior okay why would I go to
your uncle
I think Gilbert sucks penis but fYI you
know I mean that's on the down-low it's
on the DL yeah I would never do that
or even though that you do do that okay
well okay speaking of sucking dick you
know I'm not done yet I'm not done yet
you can do your notes in a second I just
want to say this I've been on the road
two weeks in a row I went to Houston and
then what did Chicago and kalila and
Gilbert are spending a lot of time when
I'm on the road behind my back George
too is involved all right so let me look
it look at me right now George right now
all right
are you [ __ ] my girlfriend behind my
sly you're sloppy
yeah be on my back George look at me are
okay look at me right now you [ __ ]
Filipino [ __ ] I love you I love you to
me but don't do it don't do it if you do
I could never do it let me just see if
you do I could never do it if you do
look I can never do it he's been begging
Jessica on your round Hey
reveal that either okay you want Jessica
my girlfriend hey that's my girlfriend's
best friend you've been asking her if
you could eat her above all blatantly -
lately right you know me and I like your
boobs and I like your told me to be a
fry that's very committed be upfront I
like your persistence yeah just sayin
yeah but no I did not I'm not trying to
have sex with kaleil I'm just saying I
just want to throw it out there I'm just
saying George look at me right now if
you pretend to fix the camera yeah
you're nervous if you do there's gonna
be wrath coming your way
I trust my girlfriend you would never do
that right you ask these boys as if I'm
just an ornament in the room with no
emotions you do have emotions but you
are an ornament you got Bobby Lee's also
third last thing I want to say before
you go to your notes
thank you for your tweets about love I'm
only in three scenes so good you didn't
see it you [ __ ] alright so did I so I
love that [ __ ] I'm in three or four
scenes second season I'm I have one
episode for sure that's a revolver on my
character and I'm very I'm very very
grateful for your positive responses
Papa doesn't work much but when
Hollywood you know me it says you can do
a little bit of things you know me makes
me feel like I'm kind of relevant but my
main goal is this podcast my main goal
you know me right now is this whole
thing sweetie this podcast is not gonna
get you paid I know that but you know
what I feel good about doing it and can
I say this when people come to me after
the show and they say I loved high
Grappelli it makes me feel very very
good we should have a new rule
you only take photographs after your
show with podcast fans how do we do that
though I mean they're obviously very
vocal right so if they come up to you
and they say hey like love the podcast
and you do get that type of feedback
then I think that they should be
rewarded because the I feel I mean the
fans are family they know so much more
about you than your you know run
the mill you know person who's gonna
walk into economy at the comedy club
there there's such a part of of you okay
so there were three cars on that two
shows Saturday sold out 500 people a
show okay so at the end of my show I say
this thanks for coming out for paying
you know your heart or the money to come
same to come see me but guess what
only the podcast people get photos no
yeah no what do I say
and they're I mean it's obvious who they
are if you guys are listeners of this
podcast we should have like a code word
or if you if you pass Bobby in the
hallway or if he Bobby's lingering
outside and you say something it should
be a word but I got it
a sentence [ __ ] no that's well we can't
have people just running around a
theater saying this isn't I'm gonna say
this sentence and it's a fact and the
person in this room can deny it it's a
fact okay
George has a pink dick oh that's a good
look at me right now friend look at me
right now friend my white friend okay
your arms are pink your face is pink
what if he has like a really big black
dick though oh wow he is Nordic so yeah
weird experiments over there George has
a pink dick I think that's the first
okay if you go to any of bobbili shows
and you say George is a pink dick you
get to have a photo shoot with him oh my
god
yeah that's a privilege the privilege
yeah but you have to say it just like
that George is a pink dick yep George
George look at me right now man do you
have a pink dick
[Music]